A great place to start when
researching your distribution plan
is through Google Trends.
Google Trends is
a completely free service
that allows you to see
the popularity of search terms
in relation to the total volume
of search terms across the world.
And in various languages.
Google processes over 40,000 search
queries every single second, and
they're willing to share
those insights with you.
The reason why this is a great place to
start is that not only can you see some
really interesting things from
all of these search queries,
like the most searched topic of the day.
But you can also see the history
of these search terms and
of related terms for your business.
So I have Ronnie here with me,
let's use her expertise to dive
into Google Trends a little bit.
>> Let's go to Google Trends and
see what comes up.
Let's go to explore topics and
type in pet sitting.
So we see here that interest over
time is relatively consistent,
although I see that there are some big-
>> Yeah, that's interesting.
>> If you look at the dates, yeah,
you can see that there
is a peak every summer.
>> Oh yeah.
>> So people are searching more for pet
sitting during their summer vacations.
>> Yeah and maybe not as much
during their holiday vacations,
that's interesting.
>> Yeah let's scroll down.
>> So what are these regional interests?
>> Here we can see where
the search term is most popular.
>> So
like the United States is most popular?
>> Yeah, you can see here
the United States, it has 100.
So this is where
the search is most common.
The place with the greatest
volume will always have 100, and
then all the other numbers here
are always relative to the 100 number.
Okay, so we see that people in
the United States, Canada, Australia and
even the United Kingdom, I guess,
are the most interested in pet setting.
>> Not exactly, we can assume that these
countries are the top ones to search
this exact search term in English.
So it's not that surprising that
the top countries are English-speaking
countries.
Let's make sure we
compare apples to apples.
So, either we compare a few different
English-speaking regions or
we decide to compare between
different search terms.
>> So, if we click on United States,
let's see a breakdown.
So pet sitting is the most popular
in New Hampshire, it seems, and
North Carolina, Arizona, Colorado.
>> Yeah, actually, we can choose
these regions as our pilot regions or
something like that.
>> Oh, that's awesome.
>> Let's go back for
a second with the world wide view.
This can also give us insights
on popular related terms.
Let's go down.
This can also give us insights about
related searches and related terms.
So in our messaging and tag line and
wording that we use in our website and
messaging, we can use not
only dog sitting, but
also pet sitters, pet sitter,
pet care, pet sitting services.
And other terms that people
already search more.
>> It's cool how they break it down
I'm sure that'll help you develop what
keywords you're going to want to use.
>> Let's go back to the top.
I want to show you
the categories section.
>> Here?
>> Yeah,
this can be very helpful in research.
So we have options like Hobbies
& Leisure, Pets & Animals,
Jobs & Education.
Categories are important if you want to
expand into the Google Display Network.
The Google Display Network allows you to
place display ads on related websites.
And you can choose where to
advertise based on categories.
What we learn here will help us choose
a category of websites to advertise in.
Clearly pets and animals seems relevant
to us, but look, under jobs and
education, the interesting
pet sitting shot up after 28.
>> That's interesting, I would have
never thought to look at this.
So what else can we find in web search?
>> Just a second, before we do that,
let's go back to jobs and
education and go back to all categories.
>> Yeah so this will show us the
interest level based on specific types
of searches.
For example, if we learn that our top
search term is super popular in image
search too, we might consider this
as another advertising option.
We can make sure that there are plenty
of relevant images that will link
back to our website.
Another cool thing you can do is
actually to compare different search
terms, and it's not necessarily for
image search, it can be for
web search too.
>> Let's go back to web search and-
>> Yeah,
let's just add another term,
like dog services.
And it's interesting to see that
maybe a few years ago, the demand was
quite similar, but recently, you can
see that the demand for the red one,
which is dog service,
is much higher than pet sitting.
>> It's interesting.
Yeah, pet sitting seems
to slowly be declining.
>> Yeah, so whether you have to decide
how to phrase your tag line or which key
words to choose for your campaign,
either way it helps you focus better.
Sometimes it can really show
you the demand of the market.
I mean if people search more for
Product X or Product Ym so
you can develop the product that
has more demand on Google Search.
Demand can be seasonal,
as you can see here.
So you could use that either to choose
which app to develop or at least to plan
your advertising campaigns around
things people search for on holidays or
in the Summer, or
around back to school, for example.
So for us, if we see in that during
summer people are searching more for
pet sitting, we know that this is
a time where we want to really,
really hit our campaigns.
>> It's surprising to see
how seasonal pet sitting is.
So maybe we should target families
more than just business people.
>> Yeah, we learned something.
>> Look at that.
Okay, well let's go to
a question about this.
Okay, so we saw this tool.
I think it's pretty awesome, and
I could have a lot of fun with it, but
I think it's time for
you to explore it a little bit more.
I want you to go to Google Trends and
explore a search term
that's related to your app.
If you don't have one, go ahead and
use Embarkment, but
don't use the same search term we did.
Then fill in the blanks below.
First I want you to tell
us what term you used.
Then what city was that
term most popular in?
Then check out the related terms.
What are the two most
popular related terms?
Add one here and here.
And finally, just for fun,
what was the most surprising thing you
found out when exploring Google Trends?